hi guys it's Tyler Oakley race had me on  the show this group last week gray stood  like a little tour of her home but  there's some things that I love and some  things that I hate so I thought I would  take you guys on my own tour I hate it  lova lova hate this plant love it hate  it this nope can stay the rest chapter  go okay I hate them they got this one  has to go Pita hate it I love it Shh  beautiful this is my favorite moon it  can stay lava I hate it I love that I  love that  somebody's missing what the fish  okay grace now that you know the things  that need to be changed in your house  please make these changes before my  episode airs this friday at ten-thirty  p.m. on e please and thank you that's  all I the grace Helbig show brand-new  fridays at ten-thirty Bonnie